Christmas it's a magical time of year
forgiving or is it retailers depend on
our generosity this time of year but how
much should we all spend on our
so-called loved ones three and ten dog
owners spend more on their pets than
their partners at Christmas but not in
my house
cocoa my dearly departed crossbreed
would get her full turkey dinner with
all the trimmings she'd obviously leave
the sprouts to last but that was it as
far as her presence went in my house my
brothers and I used to exchange a tin of
John Bull homebrewing powder as a yearly
ritual or we would really push the boat
out and give each other socks or books
we've written ourselves one garlic
ristmas I got a rubber this year I've
asked my husband for a new deep freeze
not something in a little box and my
oldest son is getting an online course
help me panel am i normal or a festive
pooper I got to say wearing an outfit
like that and asking am i normal are you
know I think you're probably enlightened
I think you may well be right I think
you're probably quite a rarity I think
most of us and certainly I love those
you know how you get cards and they have
a picture of when a woman in the 1960s
was given a hostess trolley or something
like that oh I've got a hostess right
I think we've probably moved on to those
but listen if you need a deep freeze
which if clearly you do why not do it
but I mean I won't if you don't mind I
won't tell you what but the lady in my
life I'm not giving any she's getting so
many little books yeah and this was a
rule for my dad you never buy anything
as a present for Christmas that's for
the house and I kind of grew that and
well you know my head tells me that we
shouldn't be wasting money think we
maybe don't have on stuff we already
have my you know my heart tells me and
my husband diviner earrings because I
want him to spend the time and I make
the effort to get something nice for me
did you really get a mother for
Christmas I did I think my brother Joe
gave me
this big but rich people don't let me
yeah I tried a bit of a sad life to me
well nobody will don't believe this but
we I grew up in quite a thrifty
household with no money sloshing around
so I remember before I went to prep
school for the first time I got the
driver arrived and took me to prep
school seventies Nick I got to dressing
going for my main present and I was
really thrilled it meant I would have a
dressing gown at school anyway Greg do
you lash out on all your loved ones yes
my firm I had a major saddling up with
this anymore but he is he got older he
said look if I can't eat it or drink it
I don't want to get rid of stuff as they
go well there's no doubt I mean I oh
yeah pile of stuff which goes in the
cupboard that state lusts almost a year
and then I give it to my son who gives
us raffle prizes at his Christmas
concert are you good at buying presents
for your wife I mean dude would you buy
an expensive surprise I bought a really
expensive picture I feel sorry for guys
don't you because I think you know I I
want my husband to spend a bit of cash
on me but then if he doesn't he gets it
wrong I go meant do you want to choose
your present I yeah but I don't want to
be there when he's buying it with me
what's it like it's [ __ ] round at yours
so I'm still struggling to get around
the idea of walking to Eton with holes
in your shoes yeah I think kids what a
major parts of Christmas is kids looking
forward to it and they look forward to
it because the presents are gonna get so
present giving has to be an exciting
present giving has to be an integral
part of Christmas but at the same time
18 percent of people in the UK so they
financially struggled after overspending
last year there's a guy called guy Anka
he's them he's deputy of money saving
expert oh look at what he says about
people you know putting pressure on
themselves many people love to do
Christmas present
but Christmas isn't a retail festival
and we've actually seen a bit of a
sentiment shift over the last few years
with more people wanting to give it's
five more maybe a presence or give to
charity on behalf of someone else and if
you're wondering in one of those circles
where you feel that you've got to give
to the ever-increasing number of people
and it's creating a pressure to spend
whether for yourself or for your family
or friends why not talk to each other
[Music]
when I was a kid we used to have
something called the coop saving account
where your mom and dad would put money
in every month yeah so that when
christmas came you weren't spending when
you didn't have it was already there in
the little club thing and I think a lot
of people still do it in some way or
form they do it the safe for Christmas I
know but he's basically saying we should
all go each other what do we give you
you know so they now buy events last
year we went to they bought this quick
the crystal under the crystal waves with
them and me and that's great I think if
you can buy event
yes different whereas another plastic
thing or never seeing all the fun wallet
yes I don't want to spoil the surprise
so your husband's gonna give you a deep
freeze can I ask what you're going to
give to him yes yes but he might get an
experience he won't forget experiential
giving these days yeah I think you're
right for instance last Christmas I gave
you my heart last Christmas and it was
baseball tickets for the boys for my
son's when they came to London that's a
big bounce oh so you got a big family
event and it really was when you go I
would also say that you can't completely
discard anything that's electronic
because if you get like a Playstation or
a video or a PlayStation game that's
games that you can then play with all of
your friends they live a social activity
throughout the year true true I've still
got an enormous
you can see what sort of smart efficient
design
I was enormous paid full car you know
batteries bigger kids car it's been it's
never gone never gone never driven
someone mechanical denied it's never
well why'd you put it uh say my getting
someone to take it okay